bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour ce
troisième débat des élections
départementales consacrées à la Côte
d'Or un conseil général dirigé depuis
longtemps par la droite l'UMP puis l'UDI
avec François Sauvadet depuis 2008 un
débat que nous vous proposons en
partenariat avec le bien public et son
spécialiste politique cyril biniot est
avec moi bonjour Cyril bonjour Lilian et
chez vous comme d'habitude vous pouvez
réagir sur Internet et sur les réseaux
sociaux sur ce plateau donc avec nous
pas de président du conseil général de
Côte-d'Or malheureusement puisque
François sauvaden a pas souhaité
modifier son emploi du temps pour
participer à ce débat il est donc
représenté par l'UMP Emmanuel Bichot
bonjour bonjour Colette popar bonjour
bonjour vous êtes conseillère sortante
et candidate pour le Parti socialiste
Edouard Cavin pour le Front national
bonjour bonjour Isabelle de almeidart
présente ici le Parti communiste bonjour
à vous bonjour et Dominique grimper
candidat pour le modem bonjour bonjour
je précise que vous êtes tous candidats
sur des cantons différents mais que nous
allons débattre au niveau du département
et les cantons justement c'est un des
changements de cette élection avec un
redécoupage vous le voyez sur cette
carte il y avait 43 cantons il n'y en a
plus que 23 qui auront chacun un binôme
de conseillers départementaux un homme
une femme ce qui fera au final plus de
conseillers dans l'hémicycle 46 et avant
de nous pencher sur la suite c'est le
moment d'examiner le bilan de la
majorité sortante Emmanuel béchaud c'est
vous qui la représenté sur ce plateau de
quoi êtes-vous fier que regrettez-vous
alors d'abord je voudrais dire que que
je suis fier de d'évoquer ce bilan parce
que c'est c'est un bilan depuis
un travail depuis 2008 engagé depuis
nous avons travaillé pour tous les codes
de rien et pour les tous les territoires
de la Côte-d'Or nous voulons nous avons
eu une politique pour la justice et pour
l'équilibre et nous avons voulu que
cette politique se fasse autour d'une
métropole forte et de territoire vivants
voilà un petit peu les axes que nous
avons
sur lesquels nous avons travaillé donc
nous avons mis en place des contrats
ambition Côte-d'Or avec tous les
territoires 28 contrats ces contrats
sont en cours d'exécution celui de
l'agglomération dijonnaise d'ailleurs
est très avancée puisque c'était le gros
morceau la moitié de la moitié de
l'effort apporté sur l'agglomération
dijonnaise l'autre moitié sur les autres
territoires de la Côte-d'Or pour
illustrer ce que ce que je venais de
dire sur cette équilibre entre la
métropole forte et les territoires
vivants nous avons aussi voulu avoir une
politique de proximité avec des espac la
solidarité famille 38 sur le territoire
avec avec 47 collèges publics aucun n'a
été fermé sur les territoires de la
Côte-d'Or sinon à redéploiement au sein
de Dijon même nous avons aussi 33
centres routier donc une gestion de
proximité et nous avons voulu aussi une
politique envers les familles avec le
ticket Côte d'Or 1,50 € quel que soit la
distance parcourue sur le territoire de
l'accord d'or on peut monter dans le bus
à Dijon descendre à Châtillon c'est
toujours un euro 50 le tarif unique à la
cantine
donc 3 euros 10 par repas pour toute la
Côte d'Or et les transports scolaires
gratuits ce qui ne concerne plus qu'une
quinzaine de départements en France
voilà en gros les points de bilan dont
nous sommes fiers les grands
investissements aussi sur les
infrastructures la lino le tgvs la
liaison dijonie sur tilleul le musée non
non mais je me permets de résumer de
résumer notre bilan notre bilan et tout
ça avec une dette parfaitement maîtrisée
qui diminue depuis deux ans parfaitement
saine avec 0 empreinte toxique et donc
voilà voilà notre bilan et une fiscalité
je le dis tout de suite dans la moyenne
de la Bourgogne et inférieure à la
moyenne de la Bourgogne et de la
Franche-Comté pour les 8 départements
concernés ça fait beaucoup de sujets sur
lesquels les autres invités vont avoir
envie de s'exprimer une politique
équilibrée de la part de la majorité
départementale pour vous quel est le
bilan non j'ai pas une politique
équilibrée et j'en veux pour preuve que
le Conseil Général vieux conseil général
puisque maintenant ça va être le Conseil
départemental le Conseil le conseil
général à
déserter j'allais dire ces compétences
propres pour
donner des subventions dans d'autres
domaines qui sont assez compétences ça
c'est le premier point je vous donne
quelques chiffres quand même parce que
enseignement collège on en parlait tout
à l'heure moins 71 % action sociale
moins 54% personne âgées investissement
moins 78%
total sécurité 10 les pompiers ce qui
est très important pour le territoire
moins 46% ce que je peux regretter moi
en tant qu'élu au conseil général depuis
2001 c'est de voir et surtout surtout
sur la présidente de Monsieur Sauvadet
c'est de voir que l'agglomération tout
le territoire de l'agglomération y
compris Dijon a été exclu de la de la
plupart des aides du conseil général des
exemples les crèches ne sont plus
subventionnées par le conseil général à
Dijon et dans l'agglomération les
logements à loyer modérés les pli ceux
qui sont accessibles au plus démunis ne
sont plus mentionné par le Conseil
Général alors que le budget du Conseil
général est alimenté par 50% de la
population qui réside dans
l'agglomération donc c'est pas une juste
redistribution et puis juste pour parler
de la dette excusez-moi du peu mais
c'est une dette qui explose vous avez
plus de 314 millions d'euros par
habitant au total par habitant ça fait
424 euros excusez moi en 2008 600 euros
en 2013 et vous me dites que la dette
est maîtrisée puis je ne parle pas de la
fiscalité plus 25% depuis 2008
on va venir aussi Dominique grimper oui
non juste une intervention déjà avant de
commencer le débat je pourrais faire un
constat et émettre un petit regret c'est
à dire que nous allons parler du
département de la Côte-d'Or et puis à
cette table en dehors de moi on a que
des élus dijonnais ou citoyens dijonnais
je regrette je le reproche pas d'être là
bien entendu au contraire je regrette
que il n'y ait pas quelques élus
représentant les territoires ruraux de
notre département
par rapport à l'action du Conseil
Général passé
moi je n'étais pas élu donc je suis
qu'en tant que citoyen et la chose que
je retiens de de l'action passé c'est
quand même les fameux 12% d'augmentation
il y a deux ans de taxe foncière qui
permettent qui est un coup politique qui
permet aujourd'hui quand même à Monsieur
Sauvadet de dire que ils ne montrent pas
les impôts en période électorale voilà
après pour le reste le Conseil général
est démission il doit les assumer il
doit avoir des ressources et il est
normal qu'il faille quand même aussi
voir du côté des impôts comment on peut
avoir des ressources
votre analyse du bilan
très très contrasté que j'ai fait
on a eu une note de BFM je pense que
tout le monde l'a lu donnant quelques
chiffres très intéressants la gestion
des départements des départements
avec les 100 départements français et on
y apprend que la Côte d'Or est à peu
près 50e
47e voilà donc on peut pas dire que
voilà c'est le milieu mais comme la
plupart des départements français sont
particulièrement mal gérés c'est un
palmarès qui est tourné à l'envers en
fait c'est un palmarès qu'on entend
beaucoup puisqu'on a déjà fait lion et
la Nièvre avec lionne et la Nièvre sont
en club placement bon comme on a déjà
exactement concernant les impôts
concernant les impôts on voit dans ce
palmarès que la Côte d'Or est 83e c'est
quand même énorme c'est le bas de
l'échelle c'est c'est les impôts
beaucoup trop élevés pour notre
territoire concernant la dette la Côte
d'Or et 59e avec 607 euros par habitant
ce qui est gigantesque donc non la
gestion du conseil général de Côte-d'Or
est assez dramatique je crois qu'il faut
le signaler et qui font impulser des
changements de fond vos remarques
portent plus sur la dimension financière
et fiscale que sur les compétences et
sur l'action c'est-à-dire que je faisais
un bilan
précis chiffré si vous voulez venir par
la suite Isabelle en écoutant monsieur
Bichot dans la pression que tout va très
bien sur en Côte d'Or pour pour les
habitants voilà un bilan évidemment
qu'il qu'il resterait positivement par
contre moi j'entends pas j'entends pas
monsieur bichon dire que il y a des une
baisse de dotation de l'État à la
collectivité locale quoi le département
de Côte-d'Or comme dans d'autres
d'autres départements et d'autres
collectivités locales et je pense que ça
ça pèse aussi sur l'ambition qu'on peut
avoir pour la politique au plus près au
plus près des côtes d'Orient et puis
quand même dans les coups de budgétaires
moi j'ai pas attendu et suivi et soutenu
faire des coupes budgétaires aujourd'hui
dans la prévention spécialisée où on
accompagne justement la mission de ces
du personnel d'accompagner les jeunes en
difficulté je trouve quand même que
c'est un très très mauvais choix il
pourrait mieux plutôt appuyer le projet
les projets des jeunes appuyez aussi les
missions locales qui les accompagnent je
pense ça serait un peu un peu meilleur
sur la prédication de la cantine le
tarif unique en même temps je pense que
la tarif qui est social qui pourrait
être mise en place permettrait justement
peut-être d'abaisser le tarif de cantine
pour les personnes les plus pauvres
quand on voit le taux de pauvreté qui
augmente dans notre pays dans le
département je pense que et je pense
aussi qu'une des revendications moi que
je mets aussi ou ça ne se débat là c'est
qu'il y a eu des transferts de
compétences depuis 2003 2004 de l'État
au département notamment si je prends le
le RSA la PA euh bon ça peut un peu
jargon pour les gens et la compensation
n'est pas faite par l'État ça fait
plusieurs milliards de Roux qui manquent
dans les caisses pour compenser ces
prestations qui sont des prestations de
solidarité obligatoire donc je pense que
moi j'entends j'entends pas ce matin
pour le moment cette revendication qu'on
puisse assumer
directement et pleinement les les
besoins des populations qui sont en Côte
d'Or comme ailleurs
tout le monde donner son avis il y a un
point sur lequel vous serez sûrement
d'accord Isabelle valmedas c'est la
baisse des dotations là-dessus vous
serez d'accord complètement d'accord je
moi je souhaite en parler je dirais
quand on va quand on va regarder
l'avenir aborder un petit peu le projet
des uns et les autres déjà et les autres
bien évidemment nous sommes touchés de
plein fouet par la baisse des dotations
de l'État qui a commencé les gens en
2014 mais qui s'amplifie sur trois ans
2015 2016 2017 - 20 %. donc de des
dotations de l'étape pour les
collectivités locales et la même chose
et pour les baisser même encore plus les
dotations collectivités locales et donc
avec des plans d'austérité drastiques
puisque je crois que c'est sans
peut-être plutôt 100 milliards
d'économies que vous prévoyez écoutez
rappelez-vous que Nicolas Sarkozy avait
évoqué de baissé dans le cadre
d'économie générale alors qu'aujourd'hui
les économies ne portent que sur les
dotations collectivités locales dans le
budget de l'État
Nicolas Sarkozy avait évoqué moins 10
milliards d'euros moi j'aimerais bien
avec François Hollande on en est à moins
14 milliards d'euros pour quelqu'un qui
avait juré à Dijon à Dijon au mois de
mars précédant les élections
présidentielles mais on est aujourd'hui
bien évidemment bien évidemment nous
fait au conseil général alors moi je
veux bien à chaque fois que quelque
chose ne va pas et qu'on vous pose une
question vous vous dégagez sur l'état
l'État a baissé c'est subventions point
parlez-nous aujourd'hui de ce que vous
faites des impôts des côtes d'Orient moi
je peux vous en parler de ce que vous en
faites aujourd'hui par exemple les
routes ça c'est le mode du scrutin qui
était avant on expliquera tout à l'heure
va changer on va essayer mais sauf que
on avait par exemple sur 43 conseillers
généraux il y avait huit conseillers
généraux de l'ensemble de
l'agglomération il y en a le reste c'est
33 si mes souvenirs sont bons sur
l'ensemble de le reste du département
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé vous avez
saupoudré et c'est vous monsieur Bichot
qui est responsable parce que vous êtes
rapporteur du budget c'est vous qui êtes
responsable de la politique du Conseil
Général aujourd'hui donc il va falloir
que vous assumer vous avez vous avez
saupoudré un peu partout vous voulez que
je vous donne un exemple
dans ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure sur
le budget sur le budget du Conseil
général on a pris la moyenne sur
l'ensemble des sur l'ensemble des
compétences mais quand vous regardez les
routes ça énormément baissé le budget le
budget des routes a énormément baissé
pourquoi parce que l'essentiel de
l'investissement était porté sur Alésia
et sur les routes sur les routes un
exemple pour que tout le monde comprenne
bien aujourd'hui
965 km de route ont été refaites sur la
circonscription de Monsieur sauvadé
président du conseil général sur 1164 de
fait c'est pas du saupoudrage ça c'est
quoi
ça a fait une réponse et Madame bichon
qui les autres après vont nous dire ce
qui non alors considère comme
prioritaire au sein des actions du
conseil si vous voulez madame popar
débite des chiffres mais je ne sais pas
d'où elle l'essor depuis le début de ce
débat c'est une simple petite
je resterai là
je voudrais simplement dire parce qu'il
faut que ce débat soit soit digne et
clair ne concitoyens sur les enjeux de
ces élections départementales vous ne
pouvez pas faire madame popart comme si
il ne se passait rien et que les
dotations au collectivités locales
restent comme si de rien n'était nous
sommes nous sommes dans une situation
inédite avec une la connaissance
religion à aller voter pour les
départements excusez-moi vous êtes en
train de proposer un programme ou demain
on rase gratis mais avec quel argent
vous n'avez pas compris ce qui se passe
je vous propose qu'on revienne sur les
compétences propres du conseil général
et qu'on arrête d'arroser il va falloir
faire des choix il va falloir être
courageux et il va falloir préserver
l'essentiel donc Dominique grimper
propose de le faire donc on va lui
donner la parole mais tout le monde va
le faire sinon c'est les impôts qui vont
exploser voilà c'est simple
la différence entre nous elle est là
elle est là c'est que vous proposez des
dépenses nouvelles dans pas du tout les
chapitres à tous les chapitres
je vous propose pour avancer là-dessus
et que ça soit que que ce soit d'un côté
l'UMP ou de l'autre côté le PS c'est
deux parties appliquent le stérilité au
sein des collectivités terroriales
veulent baisser les dotations donc c'est
un petit peu un débat dans le vent là
que vous nous faites parce que la même
chose que les départements sont mal
gérés puis dans votre programme vous
dites qu'il y a trop de gaspillage dans
les départements les collectivités
locales
pas du tout et je rappelle qu'on est le
seul parti qui veut maintenir réellement
le département
faut arrêter d'être d'honneur de son je
vais vous donner un exemple la ville de
pontet la ville de pontet le maire de
pontet Front national la première chose
qu'il est faite c'est d'augmenter de 44
% ses propres indemnités quand il a pris
la mairie première chose après la
première la deuxième chose ça a été de
supprimer la gratuité pour les campings
scolaires de supprimer la gratuité pour
les cantines scolaires pour les
personnes les plus en difficulté et de
supprimer et de supprimer les
subventions au Téléthon alors pour le
Front national vaut mieux être riche et
bien portant que pauvre et malade
si demain il y a une nouvelle élection
au Pontet il va être élu brillamment
c'est déjà assez compliqué de parler des
conseils généraux que tout le monde
comprend pas tout pour ne pas partir sur
la nouvelle élections municipales mais
l'échange est bien sur libre que les
Potter ne me regarde
s'il vous plaît puisqu'on parle
puisqu'on parle des compétences
puisqu'on parle des compétences la
question est pour tout le monde
finalement
si vous êtes élu si vous êtes en
capacité à l'intérieur de ce que peut
faire un conseil général on sait bien
qu'il y a une discussion actuellement
sur les compétences à partir du principe
globalement parce que c'est un secret de
polichinelle que les compétences seront
à peu près les mêmes que celles qui
actuellement et les possibilités de
faire ce qu'on veut à travers des
dérogations à peu près identiques donc
restons sur ce que peut faire
actuellement les conseils généraux
maintenant départementaux est-ce que de
votre point de vue un conseil général si
vous êtes en capacité doit se concentrer
sur ces missions primaires le versement
de l'aide sociale les collèges les
routes ou doit peut aller sur un certain
nombre d'autres choses faire ce qu'il
veut y compris le développement
économique de fortes aides par exemple à
l'agriculture alors qu'on sait que
l'agriculture aidé par d'autres fonds en
particulier européen très très
importants ou des événements culturels
ou des choses comme ça Dominique GRIMP
oui vous posez la question de
l'existence même du Conseil Général pour
l'instant il faut bien noter que la
grande partie du budget du Conseil
général va à l'aide sociale que ça soit
l'enfance que ce soit aux personnes
âgées que ce soit aux personnes
handicapées et ça ça sera maintenu de
toute façon alors à l'avenir est-ce que
les conseils généraux sont supprimés ou
pas je sais pas où est-ce qu'ils auront
des compétences strictes et pas des
compétences générales peut-être je sais
pas bon pour l'instant l'émission qui
sont assumées par le conseil général
sont très importantes particulièrement
en milieu rural quand on voit on parlait
des routes tout à l'heure un département
comme le nôtre qui a une caractéristique
quand même assez rare à savoir avoir la
moitié de la population qui regroupé
dans une agglomération et puis l'autre
moitié de la population qui est répartie
sur tout le reste du département c'est
c'est pas évident à gérer tout ça et
c'est vrai que le Conseil général a un
rôle essentiel le Conseil départemental
pardon excusez-moi un conseil
départemental un rôle essentiel moi je
suis maire d'une petite commune à lui ou
je vois que le Conseil Général
départemental fait une action importante
c'est la maison de l'enfance il y en a
une par département il se trouve qu'il
est dans ma commune et je sais que le
conseiller départemental va investir je
crois que ça a été décidé
récemment pour rénover et reconstruire
les bâtiments c'est de l'investissement
alors on peut toujours critiquer
l'investissement mais l'investissement
c'est quoi c'est du travail pour les
entreprises donc des salaires pour les
salariés de ces entreprises et puis
d'autre part c'est des emplois pour
faire vivre les structures plus tard
tout à l'heure on va certainement parler
est-ce que c'est le rôle de l'État où
est-ce que c'est le rôle par exemple de
l'aide aux communes est-ce que c'est les
départements qui doivent donner de
l'aide au commune quitte à ne pas avoir
assez d'argent pour faire le social
parce que c'est en ces termes là qu'on
peut poser la question même si
moi moi en tous les cas nous nous je
suis candidate du Parti socialiste mais
soutenu par les écologistes et les
forces de progrès c'est un largeur
rassemblement de gauche nous nous
voulons que le Conseil général le
Conseil départemental assume assume déjà
ses compétences et après regarde ce qui
peut être fait pour aider les uns et les
autres et avec un aménagement bien sûr
harmonieux du territoire ce qui n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui il y a deux
points de mesure aujourd'hui je vous
donne un exemple précis aussi parce
qu'il faut que les auditeurs comprennent
on est on est tous élus nous on sait de
quoi on parle parce qu'on a le nez dans
le guidon mais les électeurs ils
comprennent pas toujours tout parce
qu'on leur explique mal parce qu'on leur
explique mal aujourd'hui une personne
âgée qu'elle habite à Châtillon Mirebeau
Montbard ou talent à ta peau Dijon il
faut qu'on fait le Conseil Général
puisse l'aider de la même façon la
personne âgée qui commence à avoir des
difficultés pour se déplacer qui a
besoin qu'on change sa baignoire en
douche aujourd'hui elle attend trois ans
trois ans
la majorité des départementales mais
souvent en avant qu'elle est beaucoup
les communes enfin notamment les
communes rurales et vous votre position
par rapport à ça je pense que je vais
pas faire une différenciation entre
commune rurale et commune et l'urbain je
crois que tout côte d'Orient doit avoir
accès au même type de service public et
aux personnel d'une manière d'une
manière à égalité moi je pense que
justement il faut développer encore plus
de services publics dans les
départements et en parlant de
l'autonomie qu'on la perte d'autonomie
je pense qu'on aurait un grand service
public qui justement accompagnent les
personnes en perte d'autonomie qui
puisse coordonner tout ce qui se fait
sur un département et donc à égalité de
traitement pour les citoyens ça serait
une ça serait une bonne chose ce serait
donc pas assumé par le Conseil
départemental
et je reviens un petit peu le fait aussi
que les compétences du Conseil Général
pour ma part elle doivent rester il y a
des compétences obligatoires mais la
clause de compétences générales c'est
pouvoir décider de sa politique
départementale parce que les
départements sont pas tous les mêmes les
populations les mêmes doivent rester
dans dans la loi qui est en train d'être
débattue à l'Assemblée nationale
pardonnez-moi ça empêchait un certain
nombre de débordements budgétaires voir
de gaspillage financier en obligeant
l'idée que le reste du gaspillage et que
quand un département par exemple moi je
prends le Val-de-Marne que je connais
bien fait accompagne quoi fait des
crèches à des crèches départementales on
pourrait dire ça il faut ça sera
interdit demain ça voilà donc ou
d'autres compétences si je pense je
parle du sport et de la culture l'accès
à la culture pour tous et de qualité
doit rester à département peut continuer
à aider devrait continuer à aider sur
des programmes culturels dans les
communes et quand je parle de toutes les
communes pas uniquement que
quelques-unes donc moi je pense qu'il y
a cette cette question là et puis la
question de la démocratie je pense qu'il
faut avancer sur la question de de
la démocratie locale est donnée plus de
pouvoir aux citoyens dans notre
département ça peut être des conseils de
canton je pense aussi à la jeunesse un
conseil départemental de jeunes
justement
issus ou s'il y a du rural que de
l'urbain pour être mis en place pour
entendre les revendications et les
exigences des jeunes qui sont quand même
assez maltraités dans notre société ce
Cavin les compétences du Conseil Général
vous voulez voyez comment c'est-à-dire
se recentrer sur le plutôt recentrer je
crois qu'il faut déjà remettre à plat
les compétences du Conseil Général faire
un grand audit de tout ce qui a été fait
pour voir peser les pour et les contre
parce qu'il y a des il y a des grosses
dérives et vous avez des exemples
concrètement des dérives quand vous
dites que je vous ai cité en début
d'émission les impôts explosent la dette
aussi donc là il y a un problème majeur
à régler la cyladette explose et les
impôts aussi c'est qu'il y a un moment
il y a un trou il y a quelque chose qui
ne se passe pas donc il faut revoir tout
ça de fond en comble on nous parle en
face de d'augmenter les services publics
etc alors que pour le coup je vais
revenir sur l'état mais la gauche ne
fait que de les démanteler en ce moment
on le voit quotidiennement je pense que
Madame De Almeida ne dira pas le
contraire je suis pas d'accord avec vous
sur votre programme vos solutions ne
conviennent pas du tout
par ailleurs Isabelle exclure des
enfants du la cantine Vous trouvez que
ça c'est des services publics de qualité
on va au même siècle voilà bah vous on a
des exemples
de la mairie du Pontet alors je vais
reformuler je vais reformuler la
question autrement
je vais reformuler la question autrement
est-ce que on sait que l'aspect social
les prestations sociales c'est le cœur
d'éviter les conseils départementaux
est-ce que dans le programme du Front
national pour ces élections
départementales est-ce que ce qui fait
une partie du cœur programmatique du
Front national c'est-à-dire par exemple
la préférence nationale est-ce que vous
appliquerez si vous êtes en capacité
cette grille de programme à l'action du
Conseil départemental par exemple sur
l'action des mineurs étrangers par
exemple sur la version des prestations
sociales très compliqué parce qu'il
faudrait passer des lois à l'Assemblée
nationale et nous ne sommes pas encore
majoritaires à ces assemblée donc ça ça
me paraît compliqué de l'appliquer
parce qu'il y a plein de choses
je trouve pas ça normal qu'un étranger
qui réside depuis plus de 5 ans en
France et le droit au RSA alors que
certains Français n'y ont pas droit je
trouve ça anormal j'ai débattu avec lui
il y a quelques années c'était
exactement mot pour mousse qui disait
moi pour les programmes
les pas devant les problèmes que ce soit
gravés
bon moi je voudrais dire
qu'effectivement il faut partir des
réalités telles qu'elles sont et ces
réalités c'est que nous avons une baisse
des dotations de l'État sans précédent
et que l'État nous a imposé des charges
non compensées 10% d'augmentation du RSA
ça représente 5 millions d'euros pour
les contribuables codorien à absorber
sans aucune compensation nous avons
engagé une procédure au Conseil Général
de la Côte d'Or pour exiger une
compensation de l'État parce qu'on ne
peut pas gérer la décentralisation comme
ça à partir de là parce que
laissez moi
ce qui a été inscrit dans la loi je
transfère de compétences
sur un point c'est que nous sommes
d'accord sur un point c'est que c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement brouille
l'écart on change en nom vous savez
combien ça va coûter de passer de
conseils générales à conseil
départemental si on si on voulait
changer tous les panneaux du jour au
lendemain 2 millions d'euros
par an et qui coûte maintenant 2
millions d'euros par an est-ce que vous
en sortez un tous les mois
nous essayons d'informer les citoyens
sur sur les compétences je vous
conseille générale pour pour que les
gens sachent quand même pourquoi ils
vont voter parce que c'est pas le
gouvernement qui fait l'information en
ce moment bien alors ce que je voulais
dire c'est que dans ce cadre là il faut
avoir des priorités claires nous nous en
avons trois pour le prochain pour le
mandat qui qui commence au mois de mars
la première priorité c'est que nous en
matière sociale nous voulons une
politique
faire juste et ferme pourquoi parce que
tout le monde peut avoir un accident de
la vie donc tout le monde a besoin
d'être aidé et secouru mais il doit être
aidé et ce Gru pour s'en sortir pour
rebondir voilà c'est pour c'est pourquoi
nous n'avons pas du tout la même vision
de la gestion du RSA que Madame popar
avec les forces de progrès aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'on constate madame popar
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pourquoi vous
nous rendez la gestion du RSA au 31
décembre 2014 vous l'avez réclamé en
au 31 décembre 2014 à Dijon la gestion
du RSA et puis vous nous ouvrez un
chapitre qu'on avait prévu d'ouvrir plus
tard mais on va le faire maintenant
sur la gestion du RSA nous souhaitons
effectivement que le RSA soit là pour
aider les gens rebondir favoriser le
retour au travail il ne le RSA est un
contrat il n'y a pas de contraste sans
engagement de la part du bénéficiaire
nous souhaitons que ces engagements
soient respectés partout sur le
territoire et c'est pour ça que à partir
du 1er janvier 2015 la ville de Dijon a
jeté l'éponge ne gère plus le RSA sur
Dijon et nous allons reprendre en masse
cette gestion
madame popar Dijon représente 30% des
habitants 50% parler de la communauté
des habitants du département 156.000
habitants sur 526 000 d'accord
50% des bénéficiaires du RSA
l'agglomération représente 50% des
habitants du département
c'est la ville de Dijon qui le gère
depuis 2008
qui a en compétence le reste c'est le
conseil départemental je termine je
continue sur le social
des mineurs étrangers isolés qui la
plupart du temps d'ailleurs ils ont
entre 16 et 18 ans tous les contrôles
que nous avons pu faire sur sur une
centaine 60 il s'avérer qu'ils avaient
plus de 18 ans c'est extrêmement
difficile ce sont des filières
d'immigration organisées madame Taubira
au mois de mai 2013 nous a imposé d'en
prendre 14 supplémentaires alors que
nous en avons nous en avions déjà une
centaine sur les bras ce qui coûte 4
millions et demi d'euros à la au
département de la Côte-d'Or nous avons
refusé parce que l'État doit assumer la
politique de
l'immigrations
nous a donné raison le 31 janvier 2015
puisqu'il a annulé la circulaire Taubira
il vous a donné raison sur la dimension
administrative de la circulaire pas
forcément sur l'organisation quand même
sur le pont
cette gestion de l'immigration
la Convention des droits de l'enfant
c'est à respecter c'est la mission du
Conseil Général des adultes de d'une
vingtaine d'années là on est plus loin
deuxième voilà j'ai son temps de parole
on va y venir mais il faut qu'on
s'inscrire c'est le développement des
territoires et le soutien à l'économie
nous voulons continuer à investir
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on a parlé du
classement de BFM nous sommes le 16e
département de France pour
l'investissement et nous faisons
travailler des PME de Côte d'Or
de nos budgets d'investissement vont à
des PME de Côte d'Or que nous en 2008
c'était 60% nous avons une charte avec
les PME decodeur pour faire travailler
les entreprises de CODOR nous allons
continuer et la troisième priorité c'est
c'est ce sont les familles parce que les
familles aujourd'hui sont victimes de la
politique du gouvernement donc nous
souhaitons que le tarif de cantine reste
unique et modéré à 3,10 alors qu'il
monte jusqu'à 6,50 € à Dijon la gratuité
des transports scolaires elle appliquée
partout dans le département
religion un enfant paye 126 une famille
paye 126 euros d’abonnement au tram et
vous venez de l'augmenter de 9%, Madame
Popa à Dijon alors que c'est gratuit
dans le reste de la Côte d'Or nous vous
donnons une dotation la ville de Dijon
pour organiser les transports scolaires
donc ne venez pas nous donner des leçons
par rapport aux familles notamment par
rapport au restaurant scolaire également
maintenir le tarif Transco à 1,50 € dans
toute la Côte d'Ivoire
et donc elle va vous vouliez réagir et
ensuite
que nous nous avons un programme pour la
Côte d'Or un projet pour la Côte d'Or
monsieur je vous présente pour le
conseil vous vous présentez comme comme
candidat sur un quartier sur un canton
du Zoé
Edward Cavin vous réagissez concrètement
les aides sociales est une filière
d'immigration parmi des dizaines de
filières d'immigration
non pas du tout non c'est une filière
d'immigration comme il y en a comme il
en existe d'autres et je trouve ça
dramatique alors c'est la responsabilité
des deux une fois de plus de l'UP et du
PS ce qu'ils font ça maintenant la main
tout le monde est au courant et ça se
passe bien ça jeune personne hier
d'autre part et d'autre part pour
revenir notre part pour revenir sur le
problème du RSA le problème du RSA c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il y a seulement 30% des
potentiels bénéficiaires qui qui qui ont
accès donc il y a un vrai problème de
communication face au RSA parce que
énormément de gens devraient pouvoir
accès pour différentes raisons je crois
qu'il y a un gros travail à faire
là-dessus mais en revanche le RSA ça
reste un très bon indicateur de la crise
parce que ça au niveau national c'est
plus 6% en un an alors je demandeur bon
pour eux pour recadrer ça juste pour que
tout le monde comprenne on sait que
puisqu'on parle du RSA on parle de de
contrôle il y a un travail qui a été
lancé enfin qui a été demandé par
François Sauvadet sur la vision de la
fraude sociale autour du RSA et on sait
qu'un certain nombre de conseils
généraux de droite ou d'opposition de
droite dans les conseils généraux de
gauche c'est la même chose en
Saône-et-Loire en particulier
agissent enfin appuie sur sur ce point
là on a bien compris Emmanuel Michaud
c'est aussi de ça devant vous parliez je
suppose en parlant des gens qui
seulement mais vous en parlera en tout
cas en tout cas il y a eu pas mal de
publicités autour de sujets de notre
gestion du reste donc on aimerait
connaître les positions des uns et des
autres sur ce sujet que vous nous
expliquer pourquoi c'est important alors
qu'il y a un contrôle c'est tout à fait
naturel c'est tout à fait naturel c'est
de l'argent public il est normal d'aller
devoir ce qui ce qu'il en est fait
maintenant on voit bien dans quel sens
c'est monté en épingle et là c'est pas
tout c'est inadmissible en réalité la
fraude elle est marginale par rapport
aux chiffres que ça représente donc il
faut pas non plus croire que en faisant
du contrôle on va gagner énormément
d'argent d'autre part la fraude elle est
pas que et pour répondre à Monsieur
Cavin parce que je pense que c'est son
idée de la part de milieu de personnes
étrangères moi je connais des personnes
qui fraude qui habitent dans des
communes s'occuper de l'agglomération
dijonnaise et qui fraude quand même et
qui sont cadres et tout ça donc faut pas
croire que la fraude elle d'un côté donc
je donne pas non plus mais il existe une
fraude il existe une faute c'est tout à
fait normal je trouve ça il faut pas
manquer comme argument électoral c'est
ça que je regrette il faut être très
ferme avec la
en France c'est peanuts quand même par
rapport
sérieuse comme la sécurité sociale et la
CNAV voilà
mais c'est pas quelques personnes
c'est 16 milliards d'euros par rapport à
l'URSSAF qui rentre pas dans les caisses
et quand on voit quand même le scandale
dernièrement HSBC ça représente quand
même 5,7 milliards de fraudeurs et là
c'est pas des gens qui sont RSA qui
peuvent aller envoyer leur argent dans
son décompte en Suisse ou au Luxembourg
on ferait mieux de mettre en place et
d'emboucher des agents pour mettre en
place les recommandations qui ont été
faites par une commission président pour
lutter contre l'évasion et la fraude
fiscale en même temps c'est quand même
beaucoup dans les caisses c'est quand
même un dossier qui a été mis en
évidence lors de plusieurs sessions du
Conseil général c'est pour ça que on
avait envie d'en parler
non seulement il est plusieurs années
en évidence mais si vous voulez ça fait
partie des points les plus importants de
la campagne électorale de ces messieurs
dames j'y vois un rapprochement avec le
Front national excusez-moi la fraude
sociale non mais des chiffres moi je
suis quelqu'un de très pragmatique vous
savez je suis quelqu'un de très concret
parce que je suis sur le terrain tous
les jours et je vois ce que vivent les
gens moi je suis pas dans mon bureau
enfermé à lire des des discours qu'on
m'envoie pour les apprendre par cœur
donc aujourd'hui la fraude sociale la
fraude au RSA dont vous parlez et que
vous et dans lequel vous écrivez dans
vos professions de foi en un écrit en
gras lutte contre la faute sociale c'est
quoi aujourd'hui au conseil général de
Côte-d'Or je veux dire vous les avez les
chiffres moi je les ai 144 dossiers sur
144 dossiers sur 10000 je répète c'est
combien et le l'expert de du budget que
j'ai en face de moi on va confirmer ce
que je veux dire au budget primitif 2014
les indus donc cette fraude ce fameux
fraude sociale que vous attendiez vous
avez inscrit 350 000 euros 350 000 euros
2015 vous attendez 300000 euros donc
vous savez vous-même que ce que vous
dites n'est pas vrai donc vous faites
tout et votre famille je vais répondre
il est complètement réducteur de se
focaliser sur ce sujet de la fraude
sociale
je n'ai pas dit que la fraude sociale
était la solution aux problèmes
budgétaires que rencontrent les conseils
s'il vous plaît je pense simplement
que la fraude sociale déstabilise le
système parce que elle elle crée une
inéquité entre les gens qui sont
honnêtes et les gens qui sont
malhonnêtes et c'est une admissible et
c'est une admissible je vais vous donner
des chiffres
parce que
si personne ne va pas la même
philosophie sur le RSA vous considérez
que le RSA est un guichet nous
considérons que le RSA c'est un
accompagnement est une réinsertion
qui cherchent du travail monsieur bichon
j'en connais dans les quartiers il y en
a plein seulement vous venez d'un
village il y a pas de RSA j'imagine vous
savez même pas de quoi vous parlez pas
on termine on termine sur ce sujet parce
qu'on en a d'autres à aborder pas y
arriver je vais vous moi je peux vous
témoigner de des commissions d'insertion
qui fonctionne bien et c'est ce que nous
allons mettre en place à Dijon parce que
le RSA est bien ce n'est pas un du c'est
un contrat c'est un contrat de
l'insertion
combien de commissions d'insertion j'ai
siéger en rencontrant des bénéficiaires
ah bah si bah regardez dans les
commissions dans lesquelles j'ai siéger
et vous verrez que les résultats ne sont
pas les mêmes qu'à Dijon pourquoi parce
que parce que si vous
devez le RSA c'est sans contrepartie et
bien vous rentrez dans une logique
d'assistanat voilà et bien moi je peux
vous avez déjà 26 ans de 27 ans qui
pensent que c'est un truc que c'est un
droit et qui pense que c'est leur avenir
et bien c'est ça qui ne va pas et c'est
cette gestion du RSA mais je pense que
si vous avez rendu la gestion du RSA au
31 décembre madame popar c'est bien
qu'il y avait un problème c'est bien
qu'il y avait un problème votre
compétence
du RSA à Dijon je pense que vous aidez
les personnes qui en ont besoin les
aider utilement et lutter pour la fraude
nous avons nous avons fait depuis 2010
le nombre de contrôles par la par la CAF
était de 400 en 2010 en 2013 nous avons
fait ce monter ce nombre à 800 en 2014
en 2014 nous avons transmis 92 dossiers
à la justice 92 dossiers de fraude il y
en a déjà 42 qui sont jugés il y en a 47
qui sont en cours de jugement les
fraudeurs si vous voulez ils minent le
système déstabilise le système parce que
la personne qui gagne le SMIC la
personne qui gagne le SMIC et qui voit
sur son palier et qui voit sur son
palier parce que vous savez la fraude
elle est plus beaucoup plus répandue
bien sûr donnez-moi une fourchette je
vous dis madame Popa si c'est une
personne seule lors de grandeur c'est
500 euros si c'est une personne avec des
enfants ça peut monter jusqu'à 1000
jusqu'à 900 euros avec 500 euros vous
pensez que ces gens se complètent dans
cette situation mais madame ils ont tous
envie de travailler c'est pour ça que je
veux
ce que je veux les aider je vous propose
Emmanuel du chocolat auquel assiste les
trois autres du RSA que de les installer
dans leur situation durablement de sujet
dont on avait prévu de parler dans cette
émission et il faut qu'on avance un
petit peu
quel centrale finalement qui a été
centrale dans la vie du conseil général
de Côte-d'Or c'est ce lieu alors
extrêmement emblématique extrêmement
visité quel musée au parc d'Alésia qui a
été un gros dossier des dernières années
qui finalement nous renvoie ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure sur les
compétences des conseils généraux
quel est votre point de vue à tous sur
ce sujet là pardon c'est par Monsieur
grimper
puisque je suis rural du plateau
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'il y avait
pas eu d'investissement important de la
part du Conseil général depuis 20 à 30
ans dans le nord de la Côte-d'Or ce
qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est que déjà
il y a eu un investissement
on fait marcher les entreprises locales
et puis aujourd'hui il y a une vie de ce
musée au parc qui fait
environ 40 emplois temps plein pour ce
secteur du département donc c'est quand
même important je dis pas que tout est
parfait il y a certainement en
fonctionnement des choses à améliorer je
me fais l'avocat du diable si il faut
combler le déficit du MuséoParc est-ce
que de votre point de vue à l'avenir ce
sera le rôle du Conseil Général moi je
pense qu'il faut soutenir d'abord parce
qu'il faut lancer sur des bons rails
vous savez au niveau de la Communauté
Urbaine on fait pareil avec tout un tas
de projets on aide aussi des projets au
niveau au niveau du département il y a
pas de raison qu'on n'est pas je crois
que la première année il y a eu un assez
grand nombre de visiteurs parce qu'il y
avait les locaux qui ont dû y aller mais
la deuxième année il y a eu un peu moins
de monde parce qu'il faut le temps que
ce musée se fasse au parc se fasse
connaître je crois qu'il y a une
deuxième partie à construire bien faut
pas hésiter il faut pas hésiter je vois
pas pourquoi on investirait pas dans le
nord du département moi je suis
particulièrement attaché vous en doutez
je suis originaire là-haut et
il serait il serait anormal entre
guillemets que que en cours en route le
département abandonne abandonne ce
projet ou le soutiennent plus Isabelle
est-ce que ça rentre dans les fonctions
pour vous du conseil général on a
beaucoup parlé du social et d'une
enveloppe budgétaire qui serait
restreint donc est-ce qu'on peut tout
faire y compris ça j'ai l'impression que
c'est certainement un équipement quand
même qui paraît comme assez
surdimensionné d'emblée maintenant il
existe il est je sais pas qu'il est
inutile en terme d'équipement il a il a
il a son utilité mais maintenant qu'il
existe il faut revoir bon est-ce que
j'en ai entendu parler aussi peut-être
la gestion et avoir un portage plus
important pour pour le faire connaître
pour avoir qui puisse être puisqu'il
existe et puis c'est une réussite mais
en même temps il est certainement il
était sur tellement surdimensionné je
crois qu'il faudrait s'entourer aussi de
tous les acteurs locaux de pour parce
que au niveau de la concertation je
pense que il y en a manqué pour la pour
la création de cette de ce lieu de cette
équipement je crois que maintenant il
faut peut-être repartir sur le bon pied
avec cette équipement
il divise un petit peu aussi au sein de
l'opposition départementale puisque
Patrick moinos le soutient tout à fait
vous 30 millions d'euros pour la
deuxième tranche
la deuxième tranche mais je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi moi on a voté pour le
projet d'Alésia et je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce qu'a dit Monsieur
grimper il faut faire des projets sur
les territoires et notamment dans cette
partie de la côte d'Or le problème
aujourd'hui c'est pas c'est pas de
d'avoir vos dépours le problème c'est
les frais de fonctionnement aujourd'hui
donc on a construit qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé pour que les gens comprennent bien
on a construit le musée au parc et là au
départ il devait y avoir tout un
aménagement qui aurait dû être fait tout
autour sur les territoires avec des
investissements privés qui auraient dû
s'installer qu'on attendait pour
permettre d'irriguer tout ce territoire
de façon à permettre
opérateur qui s'occupe de faire venir
des touristes à Dijon à Beaune d'aller
après sur cette partie du territoire or
on l'a construit et c'est là où le reste
n'a pas été fait a donc il y a cette
construction de visée au parc 60
millions d'euros
un coup de fonctionnement déficitaire 3
millions de d'euros par an et on nous
proposait à la dernière session ou
l'avant-dernière c'est plus de continuer
avec un musée à 30 millions d'euros moi
j'ai voté contre en disant il va être
construit puisque la majorité mais il
faut arrêter il faut revoir comment on
peut bien sûr que c'est un outil
indispensable pour une heure de la Côte
d'Or mais il faut voir maintenant
comment on le gère différemment et nous
dès qu'on sera
majoritaire en Conseil Général de la
Côte-d'Or nous prendrons le taureau par
les cornes si j'ose m'exprimer ainsi
pour apporter sur ce territoire les
infrastructures qu'il faut nous
prendrons des contacts par exemple
l'office du tourisme de de venir à nello
n'a pas pu s'installer au sein du
muséopard pour des raisons politiciennes
parce que la présidente de l'office du
tourisme n'était pas le même bord
politique que Monsieur sauvadé et ben
écoutez rien que ça donc il construisent
un peu plus loin vers la gare rien que
ça ça montre bien qu'il y a pas une
cohérence dans pour l'ensemble du
territoire et c'est ce qui fait que ce
projet marche pas il y a de moins en
moins de visiteurs mais parce que si
vous voulez le visiteur il prend une
demi-journée pour visiter une mise au
point puis après il est là tout seul il
fait rien donc il faut vraiment
réorganiser tout ça nous on est prêt à
le faire est-ce que ça fait partie pour
vous du rôle d'un conseil général de
soutenir construire un lieu comme
celui-là soutenir oui ça aurait pu
l'être après prendre l'initiative tout
seul de faire un aussi gros projet assez
surdimensionner il faut le dire je ne
pense pas je pense que ça doit être des
choses qui doit être qui doivent être
plus
mise en avant avec l'ensemble de de
différents partenaires et j'en reviens
un petit peu à notre programme national
mais l'état stratège je pense que l'État
pourrait aussi rentrer dans dans les
négociations etc au moment de ces grands
projets parce que on voit aujourd'hui
que ça mine complètement le budget du
Conseil général de Côte-d'Or il y a de
moins en moins de visiteurs autour il
n'y a pas grand chose moi je connais
bien je suis originaire aussi à la base
de juste à côté donc c'est un endroit où
je suis allé plusieurs fois c'est assez
déserté il faut bien le dire donc on se
retrouve dans une situation où on a très
bel endroit très bien conçu mais qui
n'attire pas de visiteurs monsieur
vous êtes abstenus sur le vote de la
deuxième tranche de 30 millions d'euros
vous êtes le seul dans la majorité bien
alors d'abord je d'abord c'est un vote
qui a eu lieu à bulletin secret donc je
ne sais pas de vous prenez vos
renseignements
et je voudrais remettre le débat
d'Alésia un petit peu en perspective
d'abord c'est un projet qui a été voté à
l'unanimité pour le centre
d'interprétation à l'unanimité madame
popar vous étiez présente j'étais
présent
ce projet a été voté à l'unanimité
deuxièmement je pense que c'est quand
même un succès puisque cette cette
ce lieu de ce lieu est maintenant le
troisième le plus visité de Côte-d'Or
derrière les Hospices de Beaune et
derrière le musée des Beaux-Arts de
Dijon donc en partant nous sommes nous
partons de 30 000 de 30000 visiteurs sur
le site d'Alésia avec l'ouverture de son
interprétation nous sommes arrivés à 140
000 bon aujourd'hui c'est ça redimitue
un petit peu mais on se maintient un
niveau très élevé de 3e site le plus
visité de la Côte d'Or je pense que deux
points de vue là c'est un réel succès et
effectivement pour l'équilibre de pour
l'équilibre à trouver malheureusement
non non mais je veux dire il faut que
nous sommes quand même des conseillers
généraux de la Côte d'Or et le Conseil
général n'est pas une annexe de la
mairie de Dijon madame le Conseil
mairie de Dijon comme vous le
souhaiteriez nous travaillons pour la
Côte d'Or c'est à dire pour Dijon et
pour tous les territoires et croyez-moi
Dijon Dijon est très bien servi ou très
bien
je peux même vous donner de la liste de
toutes les de tous les groupes scolaires
dans votre canton qui ont été aidés par
le Conseil Général
quelques instants elle est ainsi
d'entraînement sur le territoire
effectivement
pour l'agriculture hein Côte d'Or
Cavin dit les le monde rural oublié du
Conseil
directement
pour la culture monsieur Cavin passé
donc nous nous resterons dans une
politique équilibrée alors ça pour
ce qui concerne le le fonctionnement du
MuséoParc d'Alésia effectivement nous
souhaitons diminuer la subvention
d'équilibre c'est pour rien c'est pour
ça et d'ailleurs faut pas vous étiez je
ne sais pas si vous étiez présente quand
on a voté le budget 2015 mais nous
sommes passés déjà de 3 millions à 2
millions
et demi à diminuer ah oui vous vous êtes
présente vous vous êtes parmi les plus
présentes des forces de progrès alors
nous allons diminuer cette subvention
elle est déjà qui est passée déjà 2
millions et demi et qui va continuer
c'est pour ça aussi que nous avons créé
une société que nous avons transformé
l'établissement public en société pour
avoir une gestion plus réactive et
franchement voilà 3 millions de parents
ça fait beaucoup beaucoup
vous savez de combien
coûte combien coûte combien coûte le
musée des Beaux-Arts de Dijon au
contribuable de dijonner en
fonctionnement madame Popa au Musée des
Beaux-Arts
j'aime beaucoup Alésia mais ça n'a rien
entendu quel est le coût de
fonctionnement du musée des Beaux-Arts à
Dijon madame Popa
ça n'a rien à voir pardonnez-moi mais on
avait prévu de parler de politique pour
la suite mais moi j'ai quand même une
question
un tiers du budget d'Alésia est couvert
par des recettes par les recettes des
gens qui rentrent ou qui achètent à la
boutique le musée des Beaux-Arts de di
c'est 2% alors en matière de gestion si
vous voulez madame Popa avec avec 4 ou 5
millions d'euros déficit le musée est
gratuit tous les musées sont gratuits
qui donne le spectacle qui donne depuis
des années et qui font qu'aujourd'hui le
Front national monte donc moi je
regrette ça moi je voudrais que c'est
une minute avant 2017
il est de 27 millions d'euros pour le
centre si le gouvernement ne change pas
de politique là je peux vous le dire la
deuxième la deuxième tranche qui était
qui était le musée si le gouvernement ne
change pas de politique par rapport au
musée au parc d'Alésia madame popart
et deuxième tranche effectivement ne
pourra pas être réalisé je rentre
aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'on veut qu'est-ce qu'on
veut en Côte-d'Or on vive dans un
département où dans un département où on
vive le mieux possible quand on regarde
les collectivités que ça soit le
département ou la communauté urbaine ou
les communautés de communes les gens les
élus essayent de faire des efforts par
rapport au fonctionnement et ils y
arrivent pour la plupart pas trop mal on
essaye quand même encore d'investir dans
toutes nos structures où on est en place
et on n'y arrive pas trop mal donc ce
débat qui consiste entre le PS et l'UMP
à se critiquer systématiquement moi je
vais prendre un exemple national parce
que moi j'ai été attristé par ça la loi
Macron par exemple qui a une loi de
philosophie libérale c'est une loi de
droite on peut le dire et bien les
députés MP s'apprêtaient à voter contre
mais quand nos concitoyens ils voient ça
mais qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils disent
ben il y en a marre on va voter pour le
Front National et moi c'est mon grand
combat aujourd'hui c'est contre le Front
national c'est pas continuer MPS où il y
a des gens de qualité dans les deux PS
c'est point numéro 1 faire barrage au
Front national point numéro de fer
barrage au Front national point numéro 3
faire barrage au Front national vous
pouvez ajouter le mode m nous aussi
c'est faire l'ensemble des formations
politiques donc ne vous étonnez pas que
les électeurs viennent nous rejoindre et
lisent nos programmes et il trouve un
intérêt aujourd'hui
on laisse répondre les appels de Almeida
pour que tout le monde rattrape un petit
peu de retard mais vous aurez la parole
voudront pas s'il vous plaît
moi je pense que par rapport à l'enjeu
de ces élections pour le 22 mars moi je
suis assez désolé de voir globalement je
parle pas que sur le plateau globalement
que le débat n'est pas porté sur les
enjeux sur les enjeux départementaux fin
de compte il y a très peu heureusement
qu'on a ce débat à France 3 ce matin
mais en fin de compte tout ce que les
gens entendent c'est on parle pas des
enjeux de l'avenir et des départements
des gens premiers de des moyens pour
pour répondre aux besoins des gens et du
coup tout est dévié sur sur d'autres
questions et puis le deuxième point dont
on a l'impression que la campagne un peu
compliqué quoi parce que les gens
partirent encore des gens qui savaient
pas qu'il y avait les élections les
élections le 22 mars des gens qui ont
l'impression bah à un moment donné on a
parlé disparition du département
compétences c'est vrai que les gens
peuvent se demander pourquoi les voter
sur quel sur des compétences qui sont en
train d'être examinées à l'Assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui c'est quand même
assez c'est quand même assez compliqué
quand même d'intéresser les gens quand
on fait des réformes territoriales qui
en fin de compte risquent d'éloigner par
rapport aux compétences etc si je vous
dis en faisant là aussi l'avocat du
diable que ce qui est compliqué à
comprendre pour les gens c'est aussi des
changements à l'intérieur des anciennes
majorités avec en particulier votre
partie extrêmement offensif contre le
gouvernement ce qui change la donne de
ses élections non puisque comment le
gouvernement depuis 2012 le Parti
communiste clairement une position du
Front de Gauche façon globale plutôt
offensive
loi Macron est un projet de droite et
libéral c'est vrai qu'on peut comprendre
qu'après les forces de gauche que je
fais une partie des forces de gauche on
s'oppose à ce projet de loi Macron donc
là le spectacle qui a été donné en plus
de manière très autoritaire avec le 49-3
n'est pas les gens s'intéressent à la
politique et la plupart des gens qui ont
voté on le voit bien de toute façon qui
ont voté pour pour François Hollande au
deuxième tour et qui ont mis en place
la majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
majoritairement socialiste sont déçus
par la politique qui est mise en place
donc y compris
de m'excuser parce qu'à force de
continuer à parler du département de ne
pas vouloir parler du département et du
gouvernement mais vous vous m'aidez vous
participez au fait que les gens ne
savent pas pourquoi ils vont voter ils
vont voter pour donner une majorité au
Conseil Général j'avais brouillé
revenons revenons aux compétences du
Conseil Général et disons aux gens
pourquoi il faut qu'ils aillent se
mobiliser moi je me bats contre
l'abstention l'abstention parce que
c'est ça qui va nous faire mal le
désintérêt de la politique de nos
concitoyens si on continue à parler du
gouvernement alors qu'on va se présenter
au départemental les gens ne vont rien
comprendre c'est une élection locale moi
je suis une élue locale et je parle
aujourd'hui de ce que je vais proposer
de ce que nous allons proposer dans le
département si nous le gagnant que vous
cherchez à les EM bobiner
et à escamoter cette élection parce que
vous avez peur d'une déculottée madame
popart mais je vous dis ce que vous
distribuez dans la rue ce sont les
documents des municipales mais c'était
en 2014 les élections municipales
je pense que chacun va comprendre qu'on
parle quand même du conseil général et
du département de la Côte-d'Or à des
représentants
d'après les sondages et des
représentants dans toutes les dans
toutes les collectivités moi je suis je
trouve ça tout à fait normal on pourra
d'ailleurs ce combat de politiquement
comme ça en face par contre ça peut
avoir des conséquences je vous coupe le
journal commence dans 8 secondes ce sera
le début de notre discussion tout à
l'heure ce qui va se passer
éventuellement après le résultat de ces
élections on se retrouve dans les cinq
six minutes pour la deuxième partie de
la bonne ivre